Let's see a multi tape
turning machine in action.
Input always comes in
on the first tape and
all the heads start at
the left end of the tapes.
Our task will be to duplicate
the input separated by a hash mark.
So for example,
if the input string is 1, 0, 1, 1.
We would want to turn that into
that same input followed by a hash,
followed by a copy of that same input,
1, 0, 1, 1.
Of course we need to start
in some fixed initial state.
And the first thing we need to do, is to
mark the beginning of this second tape
since we're going to have
to rewind it at some point.
So, regardless of what symbol
we read on the first tape,
we're going to write a blank symbol
to the first slot on the second.
By the way, I'm not going to write
out every transition as I draw
the state diagram here.
Instead I'll just include
a description of the key transitions.
Next, we walk forward on both tapes,
copying the contents of
the first tape to the second.
Once we hit a blank symbol
on the first tape, we stop.
Then we write the separating
hash to the first tape.
And next we want to
rewind the second one,
keeping the head of the first tape
over the hash the whole time.
We stop rewinding once
we hit that blank symbol
we wrote to the second
state in the first step.
And now we're ready to start copying.
And we keep doing so until this
head here hits the blank symbol.
Once that happens we're ready to halt.
We've taken this string here, put
a hash mark and then copied it past it.